it's actual squid not squid flavoured
what's up guys my name is Petey plastic
and I'm here representing the American
snack team
I am Luke and Mike Sheehan student from
Thailand and I have been here for like
five months so I'm representing Thailand
and I want to know what oh my god snacks
like I'm Maya and I'm Mexican American
and I'm cartoon and I'm from Thailand I
grew up in New York City where they have
the best food they also have the best
junk food as well so I live in Thailand
for my whole life and I just came to the
sadly last year people entirely crazy
about snack there's a snack all the time
you know offer it in a classroom I just
grown up in America but with a very
heavy influence on Mexican culture but I
know my snacks okay I don't really know
what you expect with Thai food because
like the only type that I've ever had is
like pad thai here at BuzzFeed a bunch
of co-workers of mine we have type
Thursday's where we go eat Thai food
everything we don't eat the snacks
though I have no idea what to expect I'm
assuming maybe a little spice it's gonna
like punch me and the taste buds or
something maybe a little crunch for me I
expect it to be baby salty depending on
which type maybe like a little sweeter
let's go space on the food here I feel
like most food here will be sweet but
it's good and again like 15 empowers
everything that came here so yeah I'm
excited yeah I was gonna start my diet
and you had me come into this video boy
[Laughter]
so this one is lame income is like Thai
traditional food it's a food I believe
in the northern part of Thailand the
tales of is unique I don't even know how
to explain it I think it's all a little
bit and sorry okay
I think you'll like it shrimps like a
personal flavor idea mine is ladies
barbecue chips this is pretty much my
go-to snack any time
or something like that it's gonna hit
you with that Phoebe Q I have the widest
palate that you will ever see I do not
like I think that like mild sauce a Taco
Bell is spicy so this is going to be an
experience whoa the flavor just changed
like five times like it started out
tasting like lime and then I taste the
shrimp now whoa I might like this better
than that and I thought I wasn't gonna
like it I kind of taste like the
seasoning that you put on like cajun
fries
it tastes like how I imagined it would
look for it because of the barbecue
flavor it's a little sweet I think not
too sweet I like it overall it has like
barbecue shoot its taste good
I was connected all the time these are a
second favorite for me which one's your
favorite my favorite is the line one
Billy mom I've never had it I can eat an
entire bag I have had this one this is
not my favorite though my favorite it's
like a roasted squid flavoured I believe
it's Thai as well what what is a street
food in Thailand we have like these cars
that basically rose like squid squid
yeah chip yeah they surprisingly they go
really well I mean I already know what
the news tastes like love me some
barbecue I before the American one
because I feel like this one is unique
and like you should be in the mood that
you want to eat something tastes like
this if we cutie fingers but I actually
prefer this one this one is good but I
feel like it has too many flavors it had
five different flavors in one and I was
like oh so like it was a journey this is
a Twinkie it's like a sponge cake with
like cranium on the inside of it
I don't like Twinkies because I ate a
bunch of them when I was a kid and I
threw them up oh my god so this one is a
Lisa it's like a cake that has some
cream filling and
this is like a snack that's to show you
keep away to shooting on a spot day I
like cool even this is so to me this is
so Americans the size of it is just so
huge it's good very dry mm-hmm the
textures are different this one is like
a sponge
this is very bready it's extremely
extremely dry it's not moist but I'm
sure it has real sugar in it but not
like real process stuff like that this
one is really moist and he says good it
tastes sweet but not too sweet I like it
I have a Twinkie in a while so let's see
if I throw up after eating this again
this tastes like it has more love in it
I know I feel like this one has a load
for much preeminent a little too rich
for me I prefer the Twinkie over it
because of moisture but I still don't
like to told you I think that would be
fur elise' because I feel like twin gate
it's a little bit too sweet even though
it's bite size and like small and petite
and cute it still it has a lot of
personality yeah so did it mental it's
like really famous snack in Thailand
maybe but a little bit not me this is
great I was talking about but it's
actual squid not squid flavoured that's
good
basically it's just like a Thai thing
when we have a lot of food trucks
there's so basically roasted squid but
this one has sauce in it is spicy - I've
never this this is beef jerky it's
really good for you it has a lot of
protein when you bite it you have to
like rip it love to chew it it is chewy
it's mmm mouth is watering
this looks so interesting but I'm open
and willing to try it and I would feel
like I'm gonna like it whoa that is very
pungent I can smell it from here
equally I don't even eat fish very sure
yeah I love one spider
now this is not happening I like that
long I'm Mexican so I can handle the
spice this is a different type of spice
I like it I feel like we also have
something like this in Thailand and he's
calling me like that you know I'm not
sure it's like you put out a beef in the
Sun and let it dry
I think it's higher tails like that I
like this chewy it might be a little bit
too salty for me but I like the flavor
of it like except fishy but it's like
hot and spicy khmer beef jerky maybe
yeah I love b13 like when I eat snacks I
like for it to be like this for you can
like I would FIFA beef jerky or bento I
don't realize quit and spicy food but
all my face a little bit that one yeah
beef jerky no you know this was like my
childhood sex so this one is called
Shanghai this is like the thing that you
would see the most when you were young
is the same as they say like teacher
just give it away to children this is
like a vapor cake
I have Keebler fudge sticks it's quite
similar to this I'm just like oh wait
her treat with cream this one you can
like see all the layers mmm
it's just like a regular like wafer this
one was definitely more sweet it's not
very sweet but I'm sure he doesn't have
as much sugar as that does I'm a sugar
addict I'm an American so I think this
is a little bland for my taste but I
would still eat it that's good it's
sweet chocolaty the thing inside is
pretty much the same but this one I
think that helped like because chocolate
yeah cuz I think it has more sugar than
that here's the way better oh yeah I
like this one more this chocolate is
more sweet and like it's light and
fluffy this one it just feels the taste
so heavy
you know I don't like the way it sounds
when I bite it I like the way this
sounds when I buy it
wow so many flavors the time one that
was my favorite was probably the chips I
think my favorite was the chocolate wait
so for me my favorite is the chocolate
flavored beer as well but the American
one they feel like you get more
chocolate I feel like most Americans
like I like sweeter than pie snack but
pie snack have lighter tastes like sour
like Saudi and spicy but most American
snack like Saudi and sweet I mostly eat
like Mexican snacks so it was actually a
good refresher to like eat some legit
like American American sex but then also
like try some Thai snacks it's great I
like trying for from different cultures
so it is very interesting as nice to
know like the og American snacks
[Music]